Have you ever just found
yourself, you know, completely
baffled by a political figure,
Someone who just seems to break
all the rules, dodge every
prediction?
Oh.
Absolutely.
It's like watching a performance
where you know there's a trick,
but you just can't quite figure
out how it's done.
Exactly, and it feels like
sometimes the more people shout
about the trick, the more, I
don't know, powerful the whole
thing becomes.
It makes you wonder, doesn't it,
if maybe our criticisms are
actually feeding the very thing
we're trying to push back
against?
That's a really interesting and
maybe uncomfortable thought.
OK, let's unpack this a bit.
Today we're doing a deep dive
into some really fascinating
sources that try to get under
the skin of Donald Trump's
political appeal and also the,
well, the intense reactions he
triggers.
We're going to look specifically
through this lens that some
people call Trump Derangement
Syndrome.
Now, let's be clear.
This isn't about, you know,
armchair diagnosis or anything
like that at all.
It's more about how our sources
suggest looking at the specific
ways critics react, ways that
might kind of ironically end up
strengthening his position
almost against their own
intentions.
Right, it's analyzing the effect
of the reaction, not the
reaction itself as a condition.
Precisely, we want to challenge
those common labels, you hear,
you know, dotard or wannabe
dictator and ask, do they really
explain his unique kind of
power, his resilience?
And to guide us through this
pretty complex territory, we're
leaning heavily on Chris
Abraham's work Trump the
Carnival Brawler, on shame,
mockery and the art of never
flinching.
Plus some really insightful
appendices that go with it.
Sounds good.
Yeah.
And our mission here really is
to pull out some, let's say,
surprising insights.
How has Trump not just survived,
but actually seemed to use
public perception, use the
opposition in ways that just fly
in the face of, well, standard
political practice?
Right, the conventional wisdom
just doesn't seem to apply.
Exactly.
We're going to 0 in on this idea
of his apparent immunity to
shame and how the criticisms,
the attacks often get twisted or
even embraced by him, baffling
the political establishment time
and time again.
OK, so we'll be digging into
specific examples, insights
straight from Abraham's text,
trying to understand why the
usual political tactics failed
against him.
And maybe more importantly, what
does that tell us?
You, me, everyone listening
about the hidden currents in
American politics?
Things we might be missing?
It's definitely a look under the
hood, so to speak.
Yeah, It's a deep dive into how
power works, how it's perceived
in this, you know, very
performative political age we're
in.
Hopefully it gives you some new
ways to think about the whole
landscape.
Right?
Let's set the scene.
Think back way back before the
presidency.
What was the general vibe around
Donald Trump?
Well, for a lot of people,
particularly in, let's say
established circles, he wasn't
really seen as a serious
political contender at all.
No, not really.
He was often painted as, you
know, gauche.
Kind of almost a walking
punchline, right?
Right.
Cartoon version of a mogul.
Definitely, the image was all
about flash over substance.
You remember the details, I'm
sure, Stamping his name in giant
gold letters on, well, frankly
gaudy buildings.
I have every word, casinos,
towers I'm.
Trying to sell those Trump
stakes through the mail, that
became a running joke.
Oh yeah, the stakes and the
Cologne.
Wasn't there a Trump fragrance
too?
There was Trump the fragrance.
It all just added to this
picture of well over the top
self promotion.
Maybe a bit superficial.
That's how it was perceived.
Certainly the source we're
looking at Abraham's work calls
him reality TV's Tacky Avatar.
That nails it, and Abraham uses
this incredibly vivid metaphor,
calling him the human golden
toilet.
Wow, OK.
Yeah, it sounds harsh, but it
captures that mix, doesn't it?
Gleaming, self mythologizing, He
built this huge brand, but also
ultimately trivial in the eyes
of his critics.
So gleaming like gold, but you
know, a toilet.
Ostentatious, but ultimately
unserious.
Maybe even a bit.
Crass.
Exactly that blend of luxury
branding and perceived lack of
substance.
They thought that would make him
politically irrelevant.
And of course, there was The
Apprentice.
Oh, The Apprentice, that gold
boardroom.
The pointing finger.
You're fired.
Yeah, pure reality TV gold.
And some people loved it, right?
They saw a winner, this decisive
figure.
Absolutely captivated by the
showmanship.
While others, and I'd probably
put myself in this camp
initially, just kind of rolled
their eyes.
Lowbrow entertainment.
Surely this couldn't translate
to actual political capital.
That was the prevailing wisdom,
wasn't it?
That this kind of celebrity act
would just crumble under real
political pressure.
Yeah, you'd think.
But then reality hit and it was
completely different.
That initial perception, the
golden toilet idea, it just got
shattered.
Totally shattered.
I mean, think about it.
This figure, dismissed by so
many, pulls off this absolutely
unprecedented political rise.
First, the 45th president,
Which?
Is stunning enough.
Right, but now he's the 47th
president, a second non
consecutive term.
That's only happened once before
in US, sister.
With Grover Cleveland way back
when.
Exactly.
Late 19th century.
It's an incredibly rare
achievement in modern politics.
And you know, Grover Cleveland
wasn't exactly dancing to the
YMCA at huge rallies.
Probably not, but Trump does,
constantly.
He owns that space.
He does his that stiff hip to
kind of offbeat hand jive thing
and his critics, almost on cue,
jump on it.
They make memes, try to make it
look obscene or silly, thinking
this is the kill shot.
This mockery will finish him.
And it never does.
He just shrugs, maybe grins, and
does it again next time.
Which leads to a really central
point in Abraham's analysis.
He never seems to demand that
traditional respect or deference
we associate with the
presidency.
That's fascinating.
He never says call me Mr.
President, or yeah, show some
respect for the office.
No, he doesn't ask you to, you
know, genuflect.
He doesn't seem to care about
that traditional performance of
presidential dignity.
So what is he doing then?
Well, the source argues he's
operating as something else
entirely.
He is, and this is a quote, if
anything, the most durable
American trickster alive.
A trickster, OK.
Yeah, it's not about traditional
respect.
It's about a different kind of
power, a different currency.
Almost 1 based on deflecting,
reframing, maybe even enjoying
the chaos.
So putting this all together,
what does it actually mean?
How does someone laughed off as
a golden toilet, win, then lose,
then come back again, all while
basically ignoring the standard
rules of presidential behavior?
It's a.
Huge question.
It really forces you to look at
your own assumptions, doesn't
it?
How?
Maybe your initial perceptions,
your ideas about what a leader
should be, We're just completely
wrong footed by him.
It challenges that whole
framework of political analysis,
really.
OK, building on that, let's dig
into this idea.
The source calls the Trickster's
Armor shame in the art of never
flinching.
This is where it gets really
interesting, I think.
Yeah, because this ties directly
into that concept.
We mentioned Trump Derangement
Syndrome not as a diagnosis, but
as Abraham uses it, a way to see
how those intense reactions of
the constant criticism might
actually backfire.
Right.
How the nature of the opposition
paradoxically strengthened him.
Exactly.
The source points out this
puzzle that the Beltway, you
know, the Washington
establishment, just never seemed
to solve.
Which is which Is that other
politicians?
Almost all of them.
They crack when they're mocked.
They get brittle, defensive when
you find a chink in that
carefully polished armor they
wear.
It's like a universal political
vulnerability.
Shame, embarrassment.
They're powerful weapons,
usually.
Usually and Abraham's source
give some really specific,
almost wince inducing examples.
Think about Hillary Clinton, OK?
The source paints this picture
of her clutching her lawyer's
briefcase of credentials so
tightly that every insult drew
blood, like she was holding on
to her qualifications for dear
life.
Wow, that's a strong image.
The valedictorian's pin wanting
that role of historic
stateswoman.
So badly, the source says, that
every insult left a Welt.
It physically hurt her image.
Maybe her personally too.
She's described as a Pearl
clutcher.
Sensitive to disrespect, trying
constantly to defend her
legitimacy.
And that vulnerability showed.
Totally.
Then there's Joe Biden.
The source suggests he bristles
at unscripted slights.
You hear it sometimes, right?
That sharp?
Come on man.
Yeah, it feels like a reflex, a
tell.
Like the source says, the mask
slips.
Reveals that chip on his
shoulder, that defensiveness
paper fins, skin, a short fuse
when his dignity feels
challenged.
Which can lead to those awkward
moments, those gaffes when he's
clearly reacting defensively.
Exactly.
And Ron De Santis, even him with
the Ivy League background, the
tough guy governor image.
He still winces every time
someone calls him short.
Right.
The short jokes, the stuff about
his boots, it clearly gets to
him.
You can see it.
And that makes him seem less
confident, maybe less authentic
somehow when he reacts like
that.
And think about Barack Obama,
even someone as famously cool
and collected as him.
The ultra curated Obama.
Yeah, even he, the source says,
sometimes let the mask slip when
the world didn't give him his
due.
Bristled when really poked, like
by Fox News criticism.
It shows that even the most
composed leaders crave that
respect, that acknowledgement.
They want the room to go quiet,
the Mr. President.
That slight irritation revealed
that even his cool wasn't
totally impenetrable.
Let's go back even further.
Richard Nixon.
Nixon, the prototype for the
fragile King, according to the
source.
Paranoid.
Thin skinned.
To the point of bugging his own
offices trying to control
everything.
Ultimately undone by it,
resigned in shame because he
couldn't handle the exposure of
the criticism.
His fragility was his downfall.
Then Gerald Ford.
The placeholder remember EU
Chevy Chase falls on SNL.
Oh yeah, the pratfalls.
He was the nice guy who just
never fought that clumsy fall
guy narrative and it just stuck
to him to find him more than
policy.
It really did.
And George HW Bush.
Too stiff to survive Bubba
saxophone on Arsenio Hall.
I remember that moment, Clinton
playing sax, looking cool and
relatable.
And Bush just seemed patrician,
reserved.
He got hit with that Wimp Factor
label.
The source suggests he lost
because people wanted the
relatable Bubba over the
dignified dad.
That perceived stiffness cost
him and Jimmy Carter.
The moral scold?
Remember this sweater speech
telling America to turn down the
thermostat?
Feel bad about indulgence.
Yeah, austerity.
Moral Rectitude.
And the voters, the source says,
basically rejected the sermon in
favor of the pep rally.
They didn't want to be lectured.
They wanted Reagan's optimism,
not Carter's malaise.
And even current figures like
Kamala Harris or Pete Buttigieg
described as bright technocrats.
Very smart policy focus.
But they flinch at the mean
tweets.
They want politeness.
They want respectful debate.
They can come across as having
quote harpiness dialed up to 11
when challenged directly.
So the pattern is clear.
Defend, explain, correct the
record, show you're serious, and
above all, avoid being publicly
humiliated.
That's the standard playbook.
Right.
And this is where Trump just
throws the whole book out the
window.
Completely.
While everyone else is clutching
pearls or bristling, he just
trucks.
He laughs at the idea of a
respectful hush.
Disarms it.
Meme him as a dancing clown.
Call him Donnie DJT Orange
Buffoon.
He'll lean into it.
He might even do the meme for
you.
Remember that Czar jerking off 2
ghosts image that went around?
He doesn't seem bothered.
He'll just grin and maybe do the
YMCA dance again.
He never seems to pull that do
you know who I am card?
Never.
He doesn't scold anyone for not
treating him with solemnity, the
source argues.
Solemnity is actually bad for
his brand.
Bad for the tent show.
Prefers the circus ring.
Exactly.
He thrives there, and the harder
opponents try to make the clown
costume stick, the more he seems
to say, OK, hand me the big Red
Nose, let's do this.
So this is what Abraham calls
the Trickster's Shield.
Precisely.
He never pleads.
Don't laugh at me.
That's the vulnerable response.
What does he do instead?
He turns it around.
He tells audience.
They're laughing at you.
They hate you.
I'm just standing in the way.
I'm your shield.
Wow.
So he absorbs the mockery and
redirects it.
He.
Transmutes it into a shared
grievance.
It becomes proof that he's
fighting for them against the
elites who scorn them both.
It's political jiu jitsu,
really.
And this is the armor the
establishment couldn't crack.
They kept waiting for that final
bullet, right?
The ultimate scandal.
The tape, The indictment.
The thing that would finally
make him feel shame and
collapse.
And it just didn't happen.
Because as the Source hammers
home, you can't kill a clown who
wants to be laughed at.
You can't humiliate a man who
has no shame, Valve.
That's a powerful line.
It's the core insight, really.
If you can't be embarrassed, you
can't be erased.
It neuters the primary weapon
used against almost every other
public figure.
The source also talks about
voters hazing or nagging
leaders, right, Like a primal
test.
Yeah, like in any tribe or
group, there's this testing,
poking to see if someone cracks
under pressure, a fraternity, a
bar fight, even asking someone
out.
There's always a test.
And Trump, in this view, passes
that test every time.
Exactly.
He takes the hits, the ridicule,
the mockery, and he doesn't
break.
He metabolizes it, turns it into
fuel, and sells it back as proof
of his strength.
Proof that he's fighting their
enemies.
While the political class is
looking for someone to demand
respect.
The voters, or at least his
voters, aren't looking for a
scold.
They want the guy who grins,
takes the punch, and keeps
swinging.
That resilience, that refusal to
be cowed, is deeply appealing to
them.
OK, this is really something to
chew on.
What does it actually mean for
politics when a major leader
operates completely outside that
currency of shame?
It changes everything.
How does it change the game for
everyone else?
It makes you think, you know
about how you react to
criticism, how people around you
do.
His approach is just so
fundamentally different from
that basic human instinct to
avoid humiliation.
He turns into a superpower,
almost.
So this leads to another point.
The source makes this constant
expectation from critics, from
analysts, that Trump would
eventually change, that he'd
evolve, Maybe.
Pivot.
Oh, the pivot talk that was
constant.
Non-stop.
The idea was there had to be
something else behind the
curtain, some hidden
Shakespearean gravitas
backstage, a more serious guy
waiting to emerge.
Ready to deliver the real proper
statesman like speech.
People were saying this back in
2015 when he first came down the
escalator.
They thought winning Wood forest
him to change the weight of the
office.
Right.
Yeah, the gravity.
And even after he lost in 2020,
when he was gearing up for a
comeback, the same critics were
saying, OK, this time he'll be
more somber, more presidential,
more grown up.
They just couldn't let go of
that expectation that he'd
eventually conform to the
traditional mold.
But Abraham's analysis just
demolishes that idea, doesn't
it?
Utterly, the source says
bluntly.
The monkey dance is the whole
point.
point meaning.
Meaning there is no backstage,
there is no pivot coming.
If you've seen the rallies, you
know his audience doesn't want
evolution.
They want the hits.
Exactly.
They want Locker up, they want
build the wall, they want the
YMCA dance at the end.
And he gives it to them night
after night.
The same jokes, the same riffs,
the same performance.
There's no desire for a new act
because the old one works just
fine for them.
It's so different from other
performers, isn't it?
The source mentions Bruce
Springsteen getting annoyed when
fans just want born in the USA
again.
Or that aging comedian who hates
doing his old catch phrase.
They want artistic growth.
But Trump, the source says he'll
do the controversial lines, the
signature bits, until the end.
He sells the same hat, tells the
same story, and the crowd loves
it every time.
It's like comfort food almost.
They know what they're getting.
And the source uses this really
interesting term K fade.
K Fade from pro wrestling,
right?
Exactly.
It's that staged reality.
The wrestlers, the promoters,
the audience, everyone knows
it's a performance, but they all
agree to treat it as real within
the confines of the show.
It's the suspension of
disbelief.
OK, so how does that apply here?
Abraham argues Trump's rallies
are pure Kfabe.
He'll pose with a golden toilet,
sell you a Bible with his name
on it.
Hawks to takes sell the $50 hat.
All part of the.
Show all part of the show and he
never breaks character.
He never steps out of the kfabe
to demand you treat him like a
serious statesman.
He is the performance.
There's no difference between
the performer and the real
person, at least not when the
audience sees or cares about.
Right.
The Monkey Dance is the show.
And that, the source argues
forcefully, is why he's so hard
to cancel or debunk using
traditional methods.
He's not pretending to be
something he's not.
He's fully embracing the
performance his audience wants.
Wow.
So what does that do to our idea
of what a political leader is
supposed to be?
It completely upends it.
We expect dignity, seriousness,
gravitas.
And he offers spectacle,
performance and a refusal to
play by those rules.
He's mastered a different kind
of leadership entirely.
It makes you wonder how much of
all politics now is performance,
doesn't it?
And maybe he just took it to its
logical conclusion.
Or perhaps an illogical one,
depending on your view.
He definitely changed the game
in terms of performance
politics.
OK, let's shift to one of the
heaviest criticisms, one of the
biggest fears surrounding him,
the idea that he's a dangerous
demagogue or even a wannabe
dictator.
That language has been
incredibly prevalent.
You hear it constantly and the
imagery it brings up is frankly
terrifying.
Jack boots, black helicopters,
mass graves, barbed wire,
nightmare stuff.
The source Abraham even admits.
I once believed that too, which
shows how widespread that fear
was, even among those analyzing
him closely.
Yeah, you heard it on cable news
panels all the time, like a
constant drum beat, a dirge or a
folk song, as the source puts
it.
But the analysis offers a really
different take, doesn't it?
A provocative reinterpretation.
It suggests the real impact, the
real danger, if you will, was
maybe quieter, more American,
less Hollywood blockbuster, more
subtle shift.
How so?
It introduces this concept of
the vacuum.
Right.
He didn't bring the boots, he
brought the vacuum.
OK, unpack that.
A vacuum.
It's not about military force or
seizing power through overt
authoritarian means.
It's about a political
realignment siphoning off of
support.
A big swap.
The source calls it a kind of
political coup, but not with
tanks.
Exactly, it argues he siphoned
out the back door these
incredibly important traditional
Democratic voting group we're.
Going to be talking about.
The old lunch Pail Army.
The coal miners who benefited
from the New Deal.
The southern Dixiecrat families
who voted blue almost
automatically for generations.
Union dads, the bedrock of the
old Democratic Coalition.
And why did they leave according
to this view?
Because they felt left behind,
ignored, maybe even looked down
upon by the party they used to
trust.
And they left for a man who
never pretended to be perfect.
Someone who spoke their
language, maybe?
Someone who didn't mind looking
stupid to the elites, and
crucially, someone who never
made them feel like they were
stupid or wrong for their views
or anxieties about the economy,
culture, globalization.
He tapped into those grievances
directly.
While as this was happening, the
source suggests the professional
class performed its virtue on
TV, signaling their progressive
credentials, but maybe missing
this huge underlying shift.
Treating a massive disconnect.
And the result?
That battered Middle, the group
that used to anchor both
parties, is now outside the
traditional tent, dancing along
to the monkey show.
They found a home in his
movement.
So in this reading, dangerous
demagogue doesn't mean literal
stormtroopers.
It means he took it all from you
while we were sure he'd pick
nothing.
He dismantled the old coalitions
while everyone was watching for
a more obvious, dramatic kind of
threat.
That's a really different way of
framing the danger.
And the source looks at the
wannabe dictator label through
the lens of his actual time in
office, too.
His first term, yeah.
Despite all the noise, the
chaos, the rhetoric, all the
chaos and none of the tanks, the
predicted strongman moment never
tame.
He pushed boundaries for sure.
Ranted.
Rallied.
Staged the show, but then the
Republic moved on.
No secret courts, no
disappearances, no dissidents
being thrown out of helicopters.
The system held, however
battered.
And now in his second non
consecutive term, his 47th
presidency.
He's already part way through
it.
Constitutionally he has about
3.5 years left maximum, and
still so far no midnight purges,
no stormtroopers cleaning house.
The Republic is definitely
tired, divided.
Tired, battered, divided.
But not under a boot, as the
source puts it.
The most extreme fears haven't
materialized in that literal
way.
So why the persistent wannabe
dictator label then?
The source argues it's become a
kind of confession.
A confession meaning what?
Meaning the critics need him to
be worse than he is because they
can't admit how well the show
works.
They need the narrative of
imminent dictatorship because
the reality that his power comes
from this shrewder, more
American form of political
maneuvering and performance is
perhaps harder to accept or
harder to fight.
It misreads the nature of his
power.
That's the argument now.
Abraham includes A crucial FAQ
section here, too.
Does no dictatorship mean no
harm?
And the answer is.
Absolutely not.
No, it simply means the form was
not the nightmare many insisted
it would be.
Real harms definitely happen.
Deportations, cruelty, chaos,
erosion of norms, serious
damage.
But the state itself didn't flip
into full authoritarian mode.
Right.
The truth is messier than the
costume drama, fan fantasies,
and the other question could he
really do it this time?
Become a dictator.
What's the take there?
The source says it's possibly,
but only if you assume all the
guardrails, courts,
institutions, public opinion
would completely fail.
And it points out, tellingly,
that he had his chance with a
stronger hand in his first term
and didn't manage it.
And the clock is ticking faster
now.
OK, this is this is a really
significant reframing if the
main impact wasn't tanks and
purges, but this slow vacuuming
away of old loyalties.
This reshaping of the political
map through performance and
tapping into grievance.
What does that tell us about the
future of political parties in
America, about democracy itself,
when power can shift so
dramatically based on
performance and defying shame
rather than just policy or
force?
It's a fundamental question
about how power is 1 in health
now.
Yeah, a real aha moment,
challenging those standard
assumptions about political
threats.
But as the source points out,
even the most enduring trickster
isn't immortal.
There are limits.
Right time catches up with
everyone.
He turned 79 around the time
Abraham was writing this.
And the US Constitution is
pretty clear.
He gets this term the 47th
presidency, and that's it.
No more reruns after this.
The 22nd Amendment, so the
carnival as the source calls it,
only needs to keep going for a
defined period.
There's an end point insight for
this specific act.
But does that end point change
the basic lesson here?
The source seems to think the
pattern will hold right to the
end, that expectation that this
time the final shame bomb will
work.
It won't.
That's the prediction, the
scandal, the gaffe, the
criticism that's supposed to
finally bring him down in
disgrace.
It's not going to land any
differently than before.
He'll just keep doing his thing.
Dance wave the hat.
Play YMCA.
And crucially, he will not beg
for your respect.
He won't suddenly crave
traditional validation as his
time runs out.
Which brings us back to that
core insight, doesn't it?
Tying it all together.
Yeah, he is not the man you
thought he was, not the man his
followers think he is.
Not the man his enemies need him
to be.
He's something else.
He is, Simply put, the man who
refuses to be embarrassed.
And the source makes this bold
claim.
And in America, that is the
oldest magic trick there is.
The oldest magic trick.
Wow.
And the timeless lesson from
that?
Never underestimate the man who
never asks you to bow.
Or, put another way, never
underestimate the man who never
asks for your respect.
It's the complete opposite of
how we usually think about
political authority and
gravitas.
Totally.
His power comes from rejecting
those things.
The source draws some historical
parallels too.
For this trickster archetype.
It's not entirely new, even if
the scale is different.
Right figures like PT Barnum,
the ultimate showman, blurring
reality and spectacle.
There's a sucker born every
minute, but that kind of vibe.
Huey Long, the Louisiana
populist firebrand, very
theatrical, very anti
establishment, terrified the
powers that be back in the 30s.
And even Muhammad Ali, how does
he fit?
By breaking the mold of the
quiet, stoic athlete, the
bragging, the poetry, the
psychological games through
words, he refused to be
predictable, refused to be
silenced, mastered the
performance outside the ring.
So these figures all used
unconventional methods,
challenged norms.
Exactly.
But Abraham makes a key
distinction about Trump.
He's the first to drag the
carnival straight into the White
House.
OK, so not just a sideshow or a
state level thing.
He brought that trickster energy
right to the center of national
power.
He didn't just bend the rules,
he seemed to rewrite them,
showing that this performance
based shame immune approach
could actually win the
presidency twice.
The implications of that are
huge.
It suggests A potentially
permanent change in what works
in politics.
It could be.
Yeah.
So wrapping our heads around
this as this really unique
chapter nears its constitutional
end, what are the big takeaways
about leadership, Political
theater, What voters really
want, maybe even unconsciously?
It leaves us with a lot to think
about regarding the future,
definitely.
OK, so just to quickly recap our
deep dive today, we've looked at
the, well, the surprising
resilience of a political fan
who just doesn't play by the
normal rules.
We explore how he seems to
thrive on mockery, how
criticisms like dotard or
Dictator, rather than destroying
him, often get reframed or even
seem to energize his base.
Right, that whole Trump
Derangement Syndrome lens,
looking at how opposition
reactions might have
inadvertently helped him.
And we consider the argument
from Chris Abraham's work that
his real impact might be less
about overt authoritarianism and
more about that subtle vacuuming
of old political loyalties.
Shifting the whole landscape
under everyone's feet almost
unnoticed until it was done.
Exactly.
So as we finish up, maybe here's
a final thought to leave you
with something provocative from
the source.
The carnival never stops until
it does.
OK, what actually happens when
this specific trickster, this
particular carnival Barker, it
leaves the stage for good when
the constitutional clock runs
out, what fills that space?
That's a big question.
And will other politicians look
at his success winning twice
with this method and try to copy
it?
Will we see more attempts to
build that clown armor, that
immunity to shame?
Is that the new template?
Or will voters, having lived
through this era, maybe crave
something completely different
next?
A return to something more
traditional?
Maybe.
Who knows, But what does it mean
for the country long term that
this strategy, this performance
works so effectively for so
long?
What does it say about us?
That's definitely something to
keep pondering.
It forces all of us to really re
examine how we understand
political power, public appeal,
and where things might be
heading.
We hope this deep dive give you
some new angles to consider.
Keep watching, Keep thinking.
We certainly will.
We'll be back next time to
unpack more.